pl je rassemble la gauche rassemblée
socialiste se rassemble à gauche et sur
la base de mon programme viennent ceux
qui souhaitent venir dans les parties
république est donc bien évidemment les
les élus modem centriste de françois
bayrou avait souhaité me rejoindre sur
la base de notre programme nous avait
tendu la main
oui j'ai trouv revanche à françois
hollande de ne pas d'abord faire x
françois bayrou non ce que je pensais
qu'on aurait pu effectivement peut-être
un moment prendre plus donner plus de
considération à françois bayrou
je préciserai changé comme je sais pas
si ça aurait changé je pas sûr que
c'était le mieux
non mais enfin je pense que quand il ya
quelqu'un qui a appelé à voter pour vous
je pense qu'il faut le considérer mois